I think that we're in the middle of the
age of genetics I don't think that we're
on the on the cusp of a revolution I
mean I think with the the sequencing of
the human genome and now sequencing of
many many different genomes from a
variety of organisms have given
researchers such powerful tools to find
out new associations being able to
compare whole genome sequences from many
many different organisms one can see
what is conserved and therefore what is
very important so I think that the tools
that we've been given just in the last
ten years are tremendous and people are
just now learning to be able to take
advantage of those and yes there are of
course ethical implications of in terms
of issues having to do with insurance
and genetic privacy issues if whole
genomes are going to be sequenced who
will have that information and I think
that there are a lot of processes going
on there's a bill that was passed a
number of years ago the genetic
information Privacy Act which will limit
the use that can be made of some of this
but I think it's an ongoing process that
people need to be discussing more widely
that the the more people in general in
the population understand about genetics
the more they'll be able to have an
informed discussion about these issues
when they come up so I think that
scientific literacy is going to be
really important as these things are
disseminated more into the public in
terms of the possibility of people
having their own DNA sequence and what
does it mean and what does it mean to
them and what does it mean for franta
family members who might not want to
know that those are privacy issues and
the only way to move forward with that
is to really have an informed discussion
and to talk about it so that's why i
think that the general education in
terms of genetics is really essential
I'm excited about what's to come but i
think that along with the actual
scientific changes there's a certain
responsibility of scientists and
educated people in general to talk about
these things because i think that with
with knowledge comes power and so the
more that the lay public understands
about what we're learning in genetics
the more they can then understand how it
would be useful to them so i think it's
a very very exciting time but i think
that there's also a responsibility to be
able to discuss things in a very open
way that makes clear what implications
are and what the implications aren't
depends on what you mean by genetic
manipulation and sense of we do genetic
manipulation in the laboratory all the
time to try and test ideas about how
genes work so we will take cells and we
will change the the genes in those cells
and then be able to ask what is the
consequence of that change that's
basically doing an experiment we do that
with mice as well if we want to
understand for instance we wanted to
understand what would happen if a cancer
cell didn't have telomerase could it
still grow so we generated a mouse the
whole mouse doesn't have telomerase so
that's a genetic manipulation of the
mice but it was an important question to
know the answer what would happen if you
can completely get rid of telomerase so
i think that in that sense those kinds
of genetic manipulations are very
powerful tools that scientists have now
if you're talking about things like
human genetic engineering and those
kinds of things there are certainly
ideas about gene therapy that people
have put out there to solve various
diseases and some of the ones that
people have been looking at our diseases
that are in the blood because blood
cells are very accessible to changes and
those kinds of things don't worry me so
much except for the technical aspects of
in some cases when you try and put jeans
back into cells people have found that
then those those genes can cause other
changes which in some cases can lead to
cancer so there are clear technical
hurdles which have to be overcome in
that realm and in terms of germline gene
therapy where you may change something
permanently and in the human germline I
think that basically that is something
that's that's out of the question and
and shouldn't really be on the table I
don't think that anybody is really
discussing changing the human genetic
Jermon for ethical reasons technical as
well if we can't even get it right right
now if the science today we can't do a
bone marrow transplant that is take some
bone marrow cells and correct a defect
of a single gene in the blood put that
back in and know that the correction is
going to happen and instead these these
children developed tumors
of unknown consequences in doing that so
if we can't even do this to blood cells
we are very very far technically from
being able to do anything without having
many unintended consequences in the
germline so for technical reasons i
would say it should be completely out of
bounds and then there are the ethical
issues which again would need to be
discussed in a broader context and and i
don't know of anyone that seriously
thinks that that is something that one
should should be changing